Being sick, losing your voice,
as I did last week, it's good
and it's bad.
It's bad because I couldn't be
with you last Thursday
and Friday.
But it's good because it gave me
time to sit back and listen
and watch.
I couldn't say anything,
at least for hours and hours
and hours.
Now frankly, a lot of it
was completely depressing
and utterly predictable.
Now leave it to the Democrats
to try to turn a virus that
started mysteriously in China
into a political attack
against a US president.
This question still remains
whether or not the president
gets it.
The president is still just
not being honest and upfront
about the impact and the spread
of corona.
Corporate America knows it is
coming.
You can't have
an effective strategy to fight
something if you won't
acknowledge what it is
that you're fighting
and the risk that it poses.
All the panic pushers,
they went into overdrive
after the market closed.
It was a terrible day on Wall
Street.
Now this is part of what was
said in just a four minute
period on CNN
after the market closed.
Investors are expecting
a potential global recession
because of the coronavirus.
So we've got all of this piling
on as those worries
and those fears.
And no one really knows what's
going to happen
with the coronavirus.
Are things about to get even
worse?
This virus is going to play
havoc on the economic growth.
There's a very good chance
that we're headed into a US
and global recession.
I mean, we have
the perfect storm here.
Let's just say that it was
a series of, well,
it's going into recession, well,
it could fall further
into recession.
No, it could be the worst.
It could be the perfect storm,
one commentator said.
Well, a perfect storm with a lot
of bluster and hot air.
Now even when Austan Goolsbee,
he pointed out
an interesting possibility
of an unusually fast market
recovery.
Maybe in the summer,
things settle down.
Notice where CNN's Jake Tapper
quickly took the conversation.
There is one glimmer
of optimism for a virus business
cycle.
There is the possibility
that this thing comes roaring
back in a way
that is not
normal for a business
cycle that's driven
by other things.
And then, Rhonda, let's talk
about the travel and tourism
industry because it's been hard
hit hard by coronavirus.
We're showing some images now
from northern Italy.
They're virtually empty ghost
towns.
Enough of that good news.
Let's go back to the bad news.
Italy, are you kidding me?
Democrats don't even support
locking down our own borders.
Now they're suddenly going
to get on board with locking
down entire US cities
and towns-- what--
with the National Guard?
Oh, I can't wait to see the ACLU
on that one.
Give me a break.
Now despite all this, the public
in some ways seems a lot more
level headed than all
of the experts.
68%, very or somewhat prepared
if indeed somebody
in their family gets
coronavirus.
Well, they're getting ready.
And the facts are actually
pretty reassuring.
But you never know it watching
all this stuff.
Now while the number
of infected persons
is more than 650 now--
the death toll has increased
to 26--
the risk to the average person
does remain quite low.
We need to take care
of our seniors.
If you're an elderly person
or have
a serious underlying condition,
avoid tight, closed places,
a lot of people.
Don't take a cruise maybe.
Everyone else, wash your hands.
Use good judgment
about your daily activities,
yeah, pragmatic thinking,
especially if you've been
overseas recently in one
of the hardest hit areas.
The president's coronavirus team
is literally working
around the clock to fight
the epidemic spread
and to give the public the most
up to date information
and guidance.
They should continue to have
these no nonsense briefings
to the press, preferably I think
at the same time every day.
That would also be very
reassuring.
Now as I said weeks ago,
total transparency, even about
the bad stuff,
is going to go a long way
to calm things down.
Public is going to know we're
going to get through this.
We're America.
We do big things.
We get through tough stuff.
But apart from fighting
the medical issues
and the public health aspect
of this nasty virus,
there are four steps
the president himself can take
in an effort to protect America
from sustaining
deep economic wounds,
steps by the way that hearken
back to his original America
first agenda.
Number one, immediately send
your infrastructure proposal
to Capitol Hill.
No more delays.
If the parties were working
in good faith, this should have
happened years ago.
Call Pelosi and Schumer, bring
him back to the White House.
No more drama.
No more pointing by Nancy
or running out or photo ops
or running to the mics
or the cameras.
Just get it and on.
Number two, this morning I wrote
that the president should
propose a temporary payroll tax
cut for workers.
This afternoon it seemed
like the White House was reading
my mind.
Tomorrow we're seeing
the Senate and discussing
a possible payroll tax.
We're also going to be talking
about hourly wage earners
getting help.
So the president is 100%
committed that we will provide
whatever tools we need.
We're going to stand by those
hardworking Americans and make
it possible for us-- and put
the health of America first.
Yes, a targeted payroll tax
cut will put more money
in Americans' pockets,
an important stimulus
in rocky times.
Push the House Democrats to make
this happen.
Number three, propose a new US
industrial policy that's
good for businesses and workers.
We need to get back to Made
in America, especially when it
comes to essential items that we
cannot do without, like medical
supplies, medical devices,
prescription,
and over-the-counter medicines.
China has a virtual monopoly
on the ingredients used
in antibiotics.
We should never have allowed
that to happen.
It's time to decouple.
Incentivize companies to bring
manufacturing back home.
We need to be less
dependent on global markets
and more self-sufficient.
This latest crisis makes
the wisdom of Trump's America
First agenda all the more
compelling.
We can't keep flooding America
with migrant families
on the bogus asylum pretense
either.
We gotta be stronger
on these borders.
My final point--
while some people are being
flown back to Mexico pending
their cases, thousands are still
getting in, impossible to screen
completely.
For health, you bet--
it's impossible to do this.
Now is not the time for us
to take in any extra burdens
on our schools.
My son's schools, by the way,
are closed all week
in Montgomery County, Maryland.
We don't need any more burdens
on the schools or the health
care system.
And finally, although Trump
can't order the Federal Reserve
to lower interest rates--
independent agency--
we all should keep pressure
on the Fed to do that.
Rates should be lowered.
Another stimulus needed, you
bet.
If America enters
a formal recession,
well, Americans
across every socioeconomic
group, every age group,
every ethnicity, every state,
every county will suffer, many
greatly.
If Democrats want to stand
in the way
of these commonsense measures,
let them
go to their constituents
and defend that move.
Look, bad things happen.
And this virus is one of them.
But setting off panic
around the world
is not the answer.
We need to calm everything down,
propose smart legislation.
We'll help do that.
Now think about this.
If Trump day after day
is saying that he has a plan
that's going to save the US
economy and yet Pelosi just
grandstands, she won't meet,
she won't compromise,
she won't even allow a vote,
then Americans will have all
the information they need
to make an informed
choice in November
and inoculate the United States
from the Democrats'
virus of failed leadership.
Remember, a President Biden,
he's going to make it more
certain, not less certain,
that we're
dependent on the very country
that allowed this virus
to spread, China.
And that is not the way to go.
And that's the angle.